whether you're here in this room and
you're participating in this or you see
this video online you can then just take
a piece of paper take a pencil and then
just start drawing whether you're an
aspiring animator or you just want to be
creative maybe inspire someone along the
way is all that we can ask for so I hope
that this does that you know we just
launched the web's called omd on my
disney which is a lot more kind of much
more plugged in i guess to online
conversations that are happening so what
are all the things that people want to
do it are not already doing online and
how can we be part of that conversation
I think that's where Disney Interactive
really kind of comes in we're looking to
work with musicians we're looking at a
work with people you know who have
passion for style and fashion with DIY
oars we're looking to work with young
filmmakers you know a lot of people that
take this seriously and had kind of our
honing their art so we are definitely
you know looking to be inspired even
young animator is right that are making
animations for YouTube and that we can
find really cool ways to partner and
kind of open up the door a little bit
more I definitely think that that's a
good like place to get into I know like
like a lot of phones and stuff that um
you know they can't get made in real
life so they do something on youtube or
something cool like that I know I
bravest warriors is a web cartoon that
the guy who did adventure time did and
that's been really cool just if it's
another place where animators can you
know do their stuff that'd be awesome
there's going to be this whole new crop
of just editors people who have been
able to start editing yeah you know like
I learned how to edit on a super 8 then
because I actually went to the trouble
of getting a super 8 reel-to-reel editor
and learning it learning how you know
how long a cut needs to be 44 different
stuff and but it was only because I had
the access to that little piece of
machinery and now anybody with a
computer and/or
for that matter of phone can learn how
to add it if they want to and people are
doing some amazing wonderful stuff with
with footage from old movies and stuff
like that that's the joy now I mean if
you're an animator and somebody who's
got a story that they want to tell in
that medium there are a million in one
reasonably priced to downright free
tools available for you to do that and
so it's it's it's never been a more
exciting timing that sounds like a
slogan it's never been a more exciting
time but anybody can go out there and
tell their stories and get it out there
for people to see that's just really
cool
it's really about story and character
and story because there's a lot of
animation going on that there's really
cool to look at that doesn't draw you in
and if you can get people to care about
the story it doesn't matter how good the
filmmaking is and it's sort of the same
with animations if you get drawn into it
you know it can be south parking be
little circles and squares put together
to look sort of like kids and if you
care about what's going on on the screen
that's all that matter it was one of
that's the that's the thing that sets
the good people apart
the natalie tran communitychannel is
just constantly funny she's not
uploading as often as she used to yeah
makes me angry but yeah but